So we've talked about if-then-else and switch statements as 1 kind of branch.
Loops are another kind of branch.
So here is a snippet of CUDA kernel code with 2 loops.
So for both of these loops, assume that this function bar is what's going to take the most time,
that all these calls to bar are going to dominate the total time spent in foo.
And the only difference between these loops is that in this case we repeat a number of times
which is threadIdx.x%32,
and here we repeat a number of times which is threadIdx.x/32, integer divide.
So as a quiz, see if you can figure out which of these is faster--loop 1 or loop 2.
In other words, where do we spend total, across the whole kernel, more of our time?
And remember, we're assuming that bar is a really expensive function
that will dominate the overhead of actually calling a loop.
And roughly how much faster is it? So give me just an integer answer.